I think you're gonna like this one
remember that judge who Trump insulted
as being Mexican during the campaign it
was judge Gonzalo Curiel who is American
but has Mexican parents Trump targeted
curiel when Kyra L was the judge in a
case against the now-defunct scam that
was Trump University and Trump
previously said oh this judge he can't
rule fairly on Trump University because
the guy's Mexican which I guess was
Trump implying that because Trump wanted
to build a border wall with Mexico the
son of Mexican immigrants to the United
States couldn't rule fairly about a scam
University which by the way is
completely absurd right what Trump was
basically saying at the time was the
judge is biased against me because I'm
biased against Mexicans right that
that's effectively the argument Trump
was making which was absolutely absurd
but let's put that aside for a second
that's the world that these lunatics
live in in the just most delightful of
coincidences judge curial is going to be
hearing a case brought against the
United States Mexico border wall plan by
both environmental groups and
congressman Raul Grijalva the subject
matter is sort of technical it relates
to a challenge against waivers that were
given to the federal government about a
decade ago to get around some federal
and state laws when there's this broader
interest of supposed border security so
it's it's legal mumbo-jumbo for all
intents and purposes but the real
important part is it started as three
lawsuits Judge Kerri L consolidated the
three lawsuits into one case and it
actually could be a major legal
challenge to Donald Trump's border wall
plan if that border wall plan was ever
actually going to get off the ground and
if curiel rules against the
administration it could significantly
slow down the construction of the
us-mexico wall
what will trump say I mean if a
mexican-american judge born in Indiana
was too biased to rule on Trump
University then he must be way too
biased to rule on the us-mexico border
wall right
shirt rumpled Amanda recusal and you
know that would be absurd for him to do
but because he also demanded her accusal
over the Trump University case yeah you
know this isn't that far of a stretch
well it's part of the theme of Trump and
his administration trying to influence
what are supposed to be independent
bodies either law-enforcement bodies or
judicial bodies and that could be
through firing it could be through the
coercion of firing it could be through a
media PR campaign a sort of smear
campaign it is yet another example of
trying to get around the checks and
balances and departmental independence
that we're supposed to have in the
United States that's what it would be to
try to get curial off of this case yeah
and I think that curial could very well
rule against the Trump administration
and not just for spite for the actual
letter of the law of rice of course but
Trump won't take that too well judge
curial is a Mexican who didn't go to
Wharton
I got great grades there and he is going
to try to stop me from making America
great again
rod Rosenstein should fire curial and
putting that Judge Jeanine Pirro
tremendous was absolutely tremendous
woman from Fox News she would rule for
America first on the border wall I don't
know what's yeah and she would get to
court on time driving at 100 200 miles
an hour yeah that's right so I don't
know what Republicans are going to do
will they try to get the a
change-of-venue get the judge replaced
just more interference with the judicial
branch and as a last note any time the
us-mexico border wall comes up it's
never mentioned any more the possibility
of Mexico paying for it has anybody else
noticed that Trump said Mexico would pay
for it I don't see Mexico paying for it
I don't see any reasonable path to
Mexico paying for it it's you who's
going to pay for it actual American
taxpayers are going to pay for this wall
if it ever happens most of us who
understand well actually I don't know
about most of us but some of us who
understand that most undocumented
immigration to the United States is not
people physically crossing the United
States Mexico border
disturbing
and I hope that judge curial stays send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by brilliant which is just a
great online service that allows you to
master interesting concepts in math
science and engineering by solving fun
and challenging problems and unlike on
other learning sites when I'm using
brilliant I'm actually learning by
working hands-on with real-world
scenarios and problems you solve
challenging puzzles carefully designed
by expert educators and professionals
from all over the world they don't go
too fast they don't go too slow they
take you step-by-step through the topics
you're interested in at your own pace
and one of their principles of learning
is effective learning is active which
just makes a ton of sense right we all
learn new things in passive ways like
watching videos on YouTube which is
great but that only gets you so far
and that's when brilliant picks it up
right don't learn by watching learn by
actually doing and you can get started
right now by signing up for free at
brilliant org slash David Pakman first
200 people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
forward slash David